welcome to heads up with stapes the show
where I chase down Team PokerStars pros
to find out more about their lives away
from the table then we play a little a
heads up of our own hey guys what's up
welcome to heads up with stave so I'm
here with PokerStars team pro olivia
marie and we are doing some outdoors
activities your but I don't wanna say
outdoorsmen fine I felt like rock
climbing you know just I love outdoorsy
stuff through the mountains you still
got a mountain I'm very happy how many
like serious injuries have you had like
not like life-threatening but broken
bones trips to the hospital a call this
summer trying to do a backflip skiing
accidents horse riding accidents hell on
my head a couple of times it's not just
zip line portions to this there is
climbing and there's like jumping wings
and his ropes and there's stuff to climb
up a lot of thought it's actually I
think it's quite a faff oh man yeah
let's get this fastest time across the
treetop assault course wins the losers
got a belly flop into a mud pit at Liv's
mom's farm
turn down boy
okay no type of love dr. Jones get off
there go do it you're gonna have to use
a stopwatch to time live but I'm gonna
need a calendar okay yes I've lost
already
let's go to the bathroom oh that's a lot
worse than I thought it's gonna be okay
let's just look straight ahead not just
the fridge you know the board's move
if you're doing real good for a grandma
you're like Bambi learning to hear
I'm just gonna try out the scream like a
girl oh sweet mother God Oh God
all right so you're obviously not scared
to do stuff like you know it's stuff
like this ziplining and rock climbing
stuff like that but you also aren't
scared to play poker and do you think
that the fact that you're like sort of
fearless in the physical world helps you
be a fearless in poker or are they not
related I think they're actually quite
unrelated because doing like scary
physical activity is generally speaking
it's about clearing your mind and not
really thinking and just enjoying the
adrenaline rush and living in that
moment you know whereas poker is about
trying to suppress any emotions that
you're having and just try and think
that's clearly as possible one
experience that I remember you had at
the poker table where you were
relatively fearless didn't you like get
into like a fight with a guy the dude
kept being on the phone during hands I
kid his phone would ring he'd answer it
he's under the gun he'd look at his
cards he's speaking well of that raised
by like the dealer wasn't doing anything
I'm just like excuse me I'm one else at
the tables like oh that dudes an actual
gangster like he's mad at you he was
asking what kind like color car you
drive and so on he then comes back after
his round penalty he's staring at me
he's like nasty blue come at the outcome
in the owners go
ie my car is red and he just stares at
me in his own turns out that actually
the gangster guy had never asked what
color and this guy was just making up so
now the gangster guy just thinks not
only am i a complete [ __ ] for court
getting me you know around penalty for
him but they're actually just insane I
mean like my pleasure my car is red
well has to be expected a lost the ropes
of course challenge but also to be
expected I am a man of my word and I'm
gonna make good on the forfeit which is
to take a bath in this why I'm dressed
like a redneck I do not know what they
bought it for me and I'm gonna get it
pretty messed up
okay now live before I go in here
believe or not we actually shot a pilot
for their show and the main feedback we
got on the pilot was that they felt like
there was never any danger that the pros
we're actually gonna lose any of the
challenges so guess what
well guys that's all we've got for heads
up with States be sure to subscribe to
us on YouTube and tweet at us hashtag
it's Dave's eighth year I need a shower
a real one alright next time and heads
up with stapes we traveled this space
okay not really